the idea behind recycling is simple by
breaking old products down and
converting them into something usable
again we conserve natural resources
it saves forests cuts emissions and
means less pollution sadly it's not that
simple
recycling is deeply entwined with our
economic system and right now doesn't
make much economic sense it often cost
more to recycle than it does to just
throw things away which is bad news for
the environment this is your bloomberg
quick take on the global recycling
crisis recycling took off globally
mainly thanks to China back in the 90s
China experienced a manufacturing boom
and began exporting more and more goods
the makers of these goods were hungry
for metals and plastics to refashion
into new products and used paper to
package them up so countries like the US
were able to load the ships recently
emptied of Chinese exports with tons of
their waste everybody won the u.s. found
a huge customer willing to pay for
rubbish which now wasn't going to
landfill and China capitalized on the
empty ships returning home full of
material ready for reprocessing for
years the amount of waste china
collected grew and grew and the world
became reliant but that all changed in
2017 China has introduced new
restrictions on the import of foreign
waste the Chinese government now bans
the imports of twenty four types of
scrap it turns out taking the world's
rubbish wasn't particularly good for
China's environment China is tired of
importing our trash the decision to ban
imports sent prices of waste materials
plummeting and upended global recycling
markets creating a crisis for
communities that had relied on sales of
rubbish to subsidize the cost of
collecting it in the US the average
price of used corrugated cardboard fell
85 percent in two years to $28 per ton
in August 20 1940 riyals of commodities
just like oil gold or caviar and their
value rises and falls due to market
conditions for example when prices are
low it's often cheaper to make that
water bottle from
we drilled gas and careless recycling
can add to the cost just one pizza box
in a pile of cardboard can ruin the
whole batch as the oils in it can't be
separated from the paper fiber at the
same time big companies like Mars
PepsiCo and Unilever have vowed to cut
use of virgin plastic and pledged to use
more recycled and biodegradable goods a
feat that may need the reinvention of
some manufacturing practices so is it
worth paying for recycling saves serious
amounts of energy which in turn means
lower greenhouse gas emissions making
cans from recycled aluminium uses 95
percent less energy than mining and
using raw materials recycling Steel's
saves 60% as does recycling paper so it
boils down to how quickly we're able to
remake the way we make things as of 2018
we were on track to generate waste more
than double the rate of population
growth through 2050 so we can expect
plenty more rubbish to pile up some
communities are running out of room to
store their trash and have stopped
collecting plastic paper and glass
others are just sending material to
landfills or burning it such issues have
given environmentalists cause to suggest
a more radical approach is needed saying
we should rethink our relationship with
materials and be using less stuff in the
first place
you